Yes.
Um,
I'm Andrea yet and I've
worked all my life and um,
job has had a, required a certain degree
of numeracy, so a lot of stuff in it.
I'm a lot of stuff in insurance and
I've always regarded myself as there's a
numerous person and I suppose this whole
project came about from frustration and
seeing the way numbers are handled in
the media and in politics and in public
life in general. And it
seems to me that, you know,
set your teeth on edge sometimes some
of the stuff you hear and you read, um,
and the way that numbers are
handled and sometimes this,
it's matters of sovereignty and the
way in which they, they, the, the um,
the things are presented.
Sometimes it's very, very basic.
Sometimes there's just a question of
people not understanding what the scale of
a certain problem is and
small issues get magnified.
Large issues get, get, get, get minimized.
And it got me to thinking that sometimes
it's the question that just needs to be
asked and answered is,
is that a big number?
And so I as one dice these days,
I set up my website and the website
had one function only. And that is,
it's a single input field. You can type
in a number and press a button that says,
is this a big number?
And it goes and we compares it to a whole
bunch of reference numbers that it's
gotten a database and it
comes back and says, yes,
it's 10 times the diameter of g of Jupiter
or something like that. You know, it's,
it, it, all it does is it goes back,
retrieves the number and brings up some,
some pleasant entertaining comparisons.
But doing that work, maybe think about
the way in which we regard numbers,
the way in which we relate to numbers of
way in which we understand numbers and
big numbers in particular.
Um,
I'm thinking about it when I started
writing some of this down and tense the
book, which you see here. So
today it's all about numbers.
It's not maths,
it's about numbers.
And the way in which we think
about and relate to numbers. Um,
I mean you guys Google,
you're the monsters of big data.
But today I want to talk a little bit
about what you could do with just a little
bit of data and not with
high tech processing of data,
but just the stuff that
you've got in your head.
Just thinking about numbers and thinking
about how we relate to numbers and how
we understand numbers. So how
numbers help us understand the world.
Now you may think I'm being
metaphorical there, but I'm not.
I'm going to start a fire literally
talking about the size of the earth and I
was always told that when you do a talk,
I guess you started with the ancient
Greeks, the ancient Greek era Toscanini's.
Now you may know him because of
his connection with prime numbers.
[inaudible] the way of filtering
out the compound numbers,
leaving behind only the prime numbers,
but he was much more than that.
He was in fact the third chief librarian
at the famous library at Alexandria.
Um, and put yourself in
his position. He's there.
This is a relatively recent institution,
been founded off to the conquest
of Alexander, the great 200 BC.
The scope of the world has,
his world has expanded because of this.
And he's dealing with new information
coming in from all over the place and he's
trying to assimilate this information,
who's trying to manage it?
He's trying to pull it into
a form of a framework.
He's trying to aggressively collect
this information and deal with it.
Does that sound familiar at all
to you guys? So there he is.
He's running the library in Alexandria
and he's trying to make sense of the
world and he's using numbers to do this.
Now that's a not that he made. What's
a reproduction of a map that he made
of his known world and he's known as
the parent of scientific geography.
And while we may look at that map and
think that's a little bit dodgy, um,
it represents only about an 8%
of the globe as we know it. Um,
and it's seriously deficient
when you get down to the south,
you'll find that that word over there
on the bottom says he quite huh.
Um, and he runs out at, at
roundabout India over to the, to the,
to the right there. And let's forget
about what's going on to the west.
But that was his known world. But there's
a lot that's going on in the trial.
So you can see around the Mediterranean
basin, they are some familiar shape,
size and stuff. Let me put
yourself in this guy's position.
He doesn't have surveys,
he doesn't have telecommunications,
he doesn't have measuring devices.
He's pulling this from, from stories.
Um,
and the thing that he introduced here,
all of these lines of
latitude and longitude.
So what he's doing is he's using numbers
to put these things into the right
place. Now the two points that
are particularly of interest here,
that's where he is in Alexandria.
They on the Nile Delta and down below
down south is a place called [inaudible],
which has a,
if you can read the word that says tropic,
it's on the tropic of cancer.
And that means that that on
the summer solstice in Cyan,
the son would have been overhead.
So that is what he used
to measure the earth.
Now that's not just an ease,
it's called Sagan,
but he's showing you the technique
that we're tossing is used.
So you can see their insight in there
has a colon and they're up in Alexandria.
There's a column. Now when the
sun is directly overhead and so,
and on the summer solstice,
the column costs no shadow.
The Sun shot shines directly down a
web shop or we've chuffed well shaft.
Um,
whereas in same day in Alexandria,
there is a shutter that's being cost.
Now this is because of the
curvature of the earth of course,
and that let him calculate
the size of the earth.
Geometry. Of course, it comes from the
Greek. Everything comes from the Rick,
well not everything,
but it's a measurement of earth OLED.
So he's measuring the earth units
each using or feet, how days.
And if you like footraces the stadium
was the length of the stadium and has run
200 meters, um, in, in today's terms.
And he had a measurement there from
Alexandra to of in 5,000 stadium.
If I look on Google maps,
I see that's approximately 850 kilometers.
So you can get the equivalency.
And
of course we understand geometry
in a different way as well as, um,
shapes and styles. And sizes and so
there's a bit of geometry for you.
There's some parallel lines coming in
the rays of the sun in the southern
location inside [inaudible] you can see
that it's pulling directly in line with
a column there.
Up in Alexandria there's,
there is a shadow being cost and if
you're under your geometry from school,
that angle there must be
the same as the angle there.
So if he measures the angle in Alexandria,
he can work out what proportion of the
circle of the earth that represents and
he mentioned it to be one 50th multiply
the two together and you've got 250,000
stadia in our terms
about 42,500 kilometers.
Now that's pretty accurate for
the time and for the techniques.
That's very accurate and
there are a couple of things
I just wanted to point out
here. One is that he's using
very simple mathematics to do.
This is only a few data points
that he needs. Secondly,
he's got a big picture.
He's got a view of what's going on.
He's got a concept of what's going on
here that he can put those numbers into.
And the third thing I would eventually,
it's quite a subtle point, you know,
in a way we saw his map of the
known world, 8% of the globe.
So that was all that he knew about in
terms of places and peoples and things
like that. But he also knew
that the world was at much big,
so he knew how much he didn't know.
And I think that's an interesting
thing to think about. Now.
We jump forward
some 1600 years to a fellow
called Toscan Ellie in Florence.
It's also an astronomer. He's also a
mathematician. He's also geography.
He was one of the guys behind the
development of the mathematical theory of
perspective in the renaissance.
Um,
he was involved in the building
of the Duomo in Florence
and he's all set dealing with a flood
of new information because this is
aftermarket Marco Polos, wages
just to the east. And in fact,
he spoke to the first
merchant aftermarket,
hello guy called Nicholas [inaudible] and
he got stories from the sky and he was
also trying to assimilate this
information and pull it together.
And he too made a map.
And when he looked at his map
and when he thought about this,
he was convinced that you could reach
east by sailing waste. And guess what?
He sent that map to Columbus and it's
an app for the Columbus relied upon.
Now they're in orange.
You can see what his map looks like and
behind it you can see what reality looks
like.
And I think you can see the problem.
He thought that the ocean between Europe
and the east was about 130 degrees of
the globe. In fact,
it's about 210 degrees.
There was a whole chunk of earth that
was missing as far as he was concerned.
And of course the rest is history.
Um,
Columbus ended up in the new world
as he thought of it as a time.
And in fact,
that's what Dustin Lee wrote.
The ocean to be crossed is not
great. Therefore, by bringing up at,
or the Asiatic coat is easily reached.
Well,
numbers make a difference.
Yeah.
So are tossed and A's around
40,000 Tuscan, alien, Columbus,
we're working to around
30,000 or 25% difference.
Now it's easy to romanticize
this and think of the,
the ancient choirs all ancient
being the guy who got it right,
but you've got to admit there's some
dodgy numbers floating around there.
The 5,000 stadia exactly.
The one 50th of the globe.
Exactly. You know, maybe he'd got lucky,
but still he got the right answer.
Well that, you know, and, and, and, or
something close to the right answer. So,
um,
so there's that to be said.
Now if we look at what the
actual measurements are,
we get some tune on this there,
one around the equator of one over
the poles and a slightly different,
but they're both very, very close to
40,000 kilometers. And you may think,
well that's a bit dodgy.
That's a bit close to around number and
of course that you'd be absolutely right.
And that comes from the definition of
the original definition of the meter,
which is one 10000000th of the distance
from the pole to the equator along the
line gangs for Paris of course.
Um,
and now we start getting into numbers
that are not to do with body parts and how
long you can walk.
You're talking about measuring the globe
and the numbering system that's derived
from scientific measurements.
And we start getting into what
we might call big numbers. Can,
I'm just going to take a moment now to
think about what do we mean by a big
number? What makes a big number? You know,
40,000 kilometers around the
world. 350 million. A lot.
A number. We've heard about a
lot if you want a few years.
But very seldom is it Austin,
is that a big number? Um,
seven and a half billion people in the
world, you know, is that a big number?
And I think there's a gap in our society
and our understanding and the way we
think about numbers here. So we go
to school, we learn about numbers,
we learn to count, we learn about bigger
numbers on that. We're going to hundreds,
we go perhaps into thousands.
We've become very familiar with
numbers in a fairly limited range.
So I mean there's an example highest ever
single leanings test crickets call 952
runs for six declared,
um,
India versus Sri Lanka Columbo,
1997 and I can imagine
that number building up.
I can imagine sitting and
watching that mansion,
there'd be a six Nebia fall and there'd
be a couple of singles and slowly that
number would accumulate. I can grasp that
process that takes me to that number,
but it's almost slipping away
from, it's almost a thing, whites,
it's a big number in those terms.
And now you have, on the other side,
you have these young
scientists working in the lab.
And for them a big number may be
a very different thing entirely.
They may be thinking or
taught about regardless.
Number in a 6.02 times 10 to
the 23 the number of mole,
the number of carbon,
12 items in 12 grams of carbon.
That's a very big number.
600 billion trillion.
And when I start saying
billions and trillions,
they've got to be careful not to trip
over my words because this is where
confusion comes in.
And of course the scientists
use that notation,
scientific notation and that's fine.
They learn those techniques,
they learn those,
those algorithms for working with
those numbers and everything is fine,
but not everybody thinks in those terms.
And not all numbers I
expressed in those tournaments.
And in between those two there is a gap.
And we talking about numbers that relate
to government now miss at relate to
corporations and
resources and populations.
And these numbers are beyond
the thousands. They're into
the millions, billions,
trillions at,
you know,
I have to watch myself
even now talking to you,
not to say billion when I mean
million or trillion. And it's,
it's confusing.
And I don't think any of us really
grasps numbers very well in their cap.
We've got a good,
a good understanding of small numbers.
We've got techniques and
dealing with very big numbers,
but that's only techniques.
It's not really a a
relationship with those numbers,
but in the middle there are some very,
some important numbers.
They are important because we're called
upon to make decisions based upon those
numbers.
So what I'm going to do today is rarely
try and just focus on one of those
numbers, the global population
there, the last of those,
and just try and bring that
to life for you in in a, in a,
in a simple way.
I'm going to stop by saying how big
is a billion or we all know how big a
billion is it to the thousand
billion since 1974 in this country,
you know, 10 to the nine one was
nine Zeros. Are they going to put it?
We'll know where to begin is,
but can be. Imagine a billion.
Can we conceive of a billion?
We're going to get there.
We're going to start with how big is a
thousand I wanted to make this come to
life for myself.
So I found out my kid at university
and I said can I play with your Lego?
And I started building a lego strip. There
you go. It's the start of it. 10 yellow,
10 whites, 10 [inaudible], 10
white trying to build a strip,
a thousand Lego studs
long too wide of course.
Cause that's how it comes.
And they would guys,
I'm going from outside
the house into the house.
You can see my toes sticking
into the picture there.
And so I go and I build that strip and
you can see in the right in the middle of
that I'll put a little red brick just
to mark the point. There is another,
another year of it. Now forgive me for
flooding in this, but I'm just trying to
put us in context.
So I'm just trying to give you a
physical idea of what thousand looks like
compared to one one in a
thousand a thousand to one ratio.
And there's the whole thing.
And then as you can see,
I've numbered that up to prove it to
myself and there's a little brick in the
middle to show you the the one
compared to the thousands. Now
it's also the length of vendor
denial compared to the Oxford.
Cambridge breadcrumb is 6,800
kilometers versus 6.8 kilometers.
It's also a height of Kilimanjaro
compared to pole vault record.
It's also the height of Niagara
Falls when measured in pools.
So just trying to give you some field,
well,
you know, a thousand w w we treat,
it's unlikely we dismiss it so easily,
but it's actually quite a big number.
It's at, if you look at your screen,
you know one in a thousand this is
maybe one or two pixels on across your
screen. It's, it's, it's a
thousand is a big number.
But we had to build up to a billion. Now
to build big, we need to start small.
So even start with a tiny little ledge,
just a four millimeter antenna
and that's our starting point.
But we get an hour and he just stick
to something a little bit bigger.
Maybe we want a beetle,
there's your beetle.
And just luckily that happens to be
about a thousand times bigger than the
Andrea.
So I imagine a thousand ants lined
up alongside that Volkswagen beetle.
Now in another step, what's going to be
a thousand times bigger than a beetle?
Well,
it turns out in central park isn't a bad,
a bad choice just to have
a four kilometers and very
conveniently it's set in a
place where they numbered the streets.
So the 50 street blocks there from,
what's the time 60th to
hundred and 10th street,
that makes 80 meters per,
and you can imagine 20 beetles on each
block of New York bumper to bumper jammed
up all along central park west there,
the thousand cars.
And perhaps you can imagine each of those
cards has got a thousand ads next to
them. So now you've got a
million ants going there. Okay.
So far so good. What's a thousand
times bigger than central park?
Turns out Australia is not a bad kid.
It's just over 4,000
code does east to West.
Your gold maps coming to my rescue there.
Um,
so that's a thousand central
park's stretching across
Australia, coast to coast.
It's a million vehicles.
Then it's a billion items.
So a building that's cross Australia,
but I can't resist going one step further
and closing the circle because if we
know that a thousand or 4,000
kilometers is within Australia,
we also know that 40,000 is he a crater?
It's a 10 billion is going to take you
align the brands all around the world
circling the earth.
Yeah.
A little deviation. Now how
fast can recycle. Yeah, no,
I don't know how good your
literate, uh, literacy yet.
Literature yet knowledge has, but there's
an itinerary from, uh, from her book
and we're going from the
London regarding via Hong Kong.
You're going by a San Francisco,
we're ending up back in London and the
giveaway of course is the title there of
80 days.
So this is a planned itinerary and Jules
van's book around the world in 80 days.
That's how I feel. Yes. Fogg plan
to get around the world. And the,
how he calculated that he
could make it work the,
a map of the route that he took.
Okay.
And the two things that interesting
about that to me, one is that it's,
my name is a straight line or even a
great circle. It's um, you know, he's,
he's having to do a
fair bit of zigzagging,
especially around about southeast
danger there. Um, and secondly,
it's actually all almost entirely
in the northern hemisphere.
So the southern most
point there is Singapore,
which is pretty much on the equator.
Um, so for two reasons, well, there's,
there's two contracting forces here.
One is going longer than 40,000 because
he's going the zigzags and he's getting
shorter because he's actually going
in the northern part of the earth.
So again,
Google maps came to my rescue.
I measured those sort of point to point
distances on some key points there.
And actually it comes out not far off,
38,000 kilometers.
So I reckon that was all right.
So he do around the world in 80 days,
steam and rail was his, what was
driving him there. Now, Eric tossing,
these would have known that you could
walk around the world with about a
thousand days if you had
a right, of course. Um, we
can drive a bit faster than,
than that. Last year a
fellow called funds for, uh,
um, a copy of the thing. I'm not
afraid to say that and did
a trip around the world. Um,
Gabba Francoise Gaba,
I did a trip around the world and
they'll try Moran took him 43 days to go
around the world solo.
We commercial flights,
you can do it in two and a half days.
And I checked up on this,
you can take any New Zealand
from London to Oakland,
Los Angeles in two and a half
hours on the ground and in Oakland.
And you can take a BA flight back via
Sydney and Singapore and it takes you
exactly 60 hours,
two and a half days.
A plane has actually a B 52.
Obama has actually flown around the
world in 42 hours refilling on flight.
I'm the fastest play in the
plan is a blackbird re complain.
It didn't actually go around the world.
It's,
it did a 24,000 kilometer journey,
60% of the way in about
10 and a half hours.
So that would have been equivalent to
going around in 17 and a half hours and
the International Space Station of
course goes around about every hour and a
half,
so about 15 times a day.
But then I came across one more
measurement that I couldn't leave out,
which was from Shakespeare and he said
that he has puck saying midsummer night's
dream.
I will put a girdle round about the earth
in 40 minutes and when I saw that 40
it chimed with my 40,000 so there's
a thousand kilometers admitted,
one mega Meta permitted.
I think we should have a new unit of
speed called a pack once mega liter per
minute. Anyway, that's a
bit of diversion. Yeah.
Let's talk about the number of people
that th th th the seven and a half billion
people now you guys,
I'm sure it will know all about
this guy called Hans Rosling died.
Sandy last year.
Swedish doctors,
statistician talk, her
thinker, Wonderful Fella.
If you've not seen his videos or read
his book fact for this God and get it,
it's it's, it's a fantastic,
fantastic book. And He,
this is him talking about
the world's population.
And in the first picture there he showing
7 billion people as he had at the time
and the age distribution of these people.
So you've got 2 billion people under
the age of 15 2 billion children,
2 billion in the next traunch up to the
age of 30 and then a billion, a billion,
a billion going up to 75 and he's talking
about the wine which population grows
and the way in which
it's a predictable thing.
And he says what's happening now is
that the number of children is not
significantly increasing in the world.
What's happening is that people are
getting older and so those columns are
growing upwards but the whole
structure is not getting wider.
So he's taking it there from
seven to 10 billion by aging.
Those pop, those, those,
those, those young people.
And that is a change of pricing in the
world and how it is the way that the
population is progressing
and it takes a little bit
further and he says, yes,
people are going to be living longer
and he's putting another block on top of
there to make it into 11 billion.
Um,
and that would cover the age 75 to 90.
This is obviously a very crude and simple
terms but nonetheless it helps you to
focus the mind. It helps you to
think about these numbers. Um, in,
in the background there he's got a
little chart based on the United Nations
projection and he talks about
having reached peak child.
In other words,
for several decades now the number
of children in the world hasn't been
increasing. What's happening is
that adults are getting older,
more people are living to old age.
And I mean there's a whole discussion to
be had and the whole discussion around
all of the implications of this I which
one to pick out one thing here and that
is around 2050 around the
middle of the century,
we are going to pass the a number
of 10 billion people in the world.
Whether we go beyond that, whether
it be for, you know, when we uh,
whether it tops out.
We're not talking about that yet.
Now just a question of at some point we
will hit 10 billion and what will that
look like?
Now we've already got a
reference point for this.
We've already covered this because we
know what 10 billion ads look like.
It's a 10 billion ants wind
their way around the world ones.
Now I need a bit more space than an ENT.
If an ant gets four millimeters,
maybe I need a meter.
So Ryan of people would then be 250
times as long with wind around the earth.
250 times.
Can we visualize that?
Let's take some central parks.
If we put 10,000 central
parks around the world,
central park is 850 meters across.
It's enough space for 250 lines of people
and three meters between them and that
would be 1 billion people
sitting in each park.
So 1 billion people in 10,000
parks around the world.
Is that realistic? Well,
yes. I'm showing my age here,
but in 1981 silo and Garfunkel
reunion concert concert,
they pulled 500,000 people onto the
great lawn in central park and that had
bigger crowds in that instance then.
So there we are pushing towards
a million people in central park.
Is that realistic? Yes, it is. To think
about that. How do I numbers agree?
Yes, I do. Just a little few
validity checks and we can be,
we were happy that we were in
the right order of magnitude cal.
How dense are those people?
It works out to about 300,000 per square
kilometers and that's the direction.
Now obviously we're not trying to say
that all the people in the world can
convert at that density,
but how densely can people live?
Well, the place on earth with the
greatest population density is Macau.
I'm sort of the sister said you to Hong
Kong on the China Sea there and they've
got 21,000 people per square kilometer.
That's only 15 times as much as
those profilers in central park had.
Um,
so it's pretty dense,
but you can see there is some um,
green space.
There is a working city of a viable city.
It is a viable way of living.
So let's just do a thought experiment
here and say what happened?
What if all the world loves a
densely as they did in the cow,
how much space would that need?
Well,
480,000 kilometers squared squared.
Now you can see what I've done. There are
factories that into my favorite number,
40,000 by 12.
So you can imagine that as being a
ribbon said he stretched around the world
only 12 kilometers wide.
So think about this remote,
even from the center of that,
you could walk six kilometers,
what's it,
two hours walk and you'd get
to the edge of this, the city.
And there would be nothing between you
and the Paul. Of course, there'd be farms,
it'd be everything that we need to, to
sustain ourselves. But in terms of people,
we could put everybody in the world
into 12 kilometer wide strip around the
world.
But of course we don't want to live at
that level of density that they live in
Macao. Um, you know what,
for good or for bad,
we've chosen to live in, in England, um,
with the density is about
420 per square kilometers.
So that's about 50 times as much
space as the inhabitance of MCI.
And those 10 million people would need
around 24 million square kilometers.
And again,
factorized that 40,000 by 600.
And so we get there,
say a belt nation there.
So a country,
it's about the same
north to south as the length of England.
It's about the same as Ecuador,
which is on the equator. Uh,
and again, it's, you know,
that would have space for the lake
districts and the national parks and the
cities and the suburbia and
no more than 300 kilometers,
half a day's drive to get to the edge
and nothing between you and the poem.
Now, I'm not going to suggest
this is a practical plan,
but it's just to get these ideas in
your head of how much space it takes up.
Here's another way of
expressing it is 80% of Africa,
everybody in the world could live in that
living at the density that we live in
England. Of course I'm
oversimplifying like crazy. Yeah.
Um, and you know, 10 billion people.
Is that a big number? But
of course it is. It does.
The world of space for 10 billion
people. Well, of course it does.
But that's not that simple.
You know, we've, we've,
we've not talked about
distribution of people.
How are we not talked about the food
that they need, the water they need,
the waste they produce,
the what is needed to give those 10
billion people meaningful and fulfilling
lives.
And
Rarely, I'm not sure to
tell you that's, you know,
10 billion people is not a problem. Of
course it is. There are massive problems,
but until he start measuring
the problems they become,
they are very hard to deal with unless
you can actually start putting numbers to
some of those ideas.
You don't have a chance of actually
dealing with any of the issues.
And all I could quote from Isaac Asimov,
great science fiction writer,
if knowledge can create problems,
it's not through ignorance.
So if we can solve them,
so what solutions they come,
we will, they come from,
we talk about the 10 billion people
when we think in terms of problem,
but 10 billion people is also 10 billion
minds to think of solutions. It's also
10 billion people with inspiration,
with determination, with drive.
And it's people like you who were,
those solutions will come from it.
Smart people,
it's people who are practical,
are problem solvers.
As people who
think it comes down to it.
For people who are numerate,
those are the people who are going to get
to grips with the issues and deal with
them.
And,
yeah,
and it's not just the techies.
It's not just guys like you who can
grasp the problems and deal with them.
But there needs to be a political will
and the people with political power and
people with political,
with financial power also need to be
on board to make these things happen.
And they need to be persuaded
and they need people to spend it.
Sometimes not through big data,
but sometimes through little data,
sometimes three little points that they
can focus on that they can latch on to,
that they can invest in their minds.
And it says this communication aspect,
I think that is very
important. Um, you know,
the reporters and the
journalists of the world,
they'll to sensationalize
sensationalizing sometimes.
And it's a question of trying to ground
these and trying to bring these issues
to a measurable levels where
we can think about them.
And sometimes it's complex
and sometimes it's simple.
Sometimes it's as simple as asking
the question, is that a big number?
And rarely that simple question is
what's behind what's in the book.
Um, I talk about various ways of
getting numbers in perspective.
How do you compare numbers,
ways of thinking about them as there's
lots of sort of visualization and there
the stories about numbers.
Um,
and it's a question of getting our brains
around and being able to express as
numbers in ways that are meaningful
and those that are useful to, to uh,
to people. Um, and yeah,
so let me up. That's the book. Um, there's
a website, is that a big number.com?
I'm Andrew [inaudible]. I'm also,
I've got a Twitter feed there.
Um, those of you who have picked up a
copy of the book, I hope you enjoy it.
Um, and if anybody got any
questions, I'm happy to answer.
You say it's important to get a grip of
numbers and understand and put them into
relation, uh, big numbers especially. Um,
how do you suggest we help people do that?
Um,
because lots of people,
probably all of us struggle with very big
numbers and putting them in relations.
I mean, I've talked through in the
book various techniques. The top one,
the landmark numbers is one
that I think is very important.
What I mean by landmark number,
it's something that you,
that sticks in your brain,
you don't set out to memorize it,
but it sticks in your
brain as a reference point.
And I hope that all of you will leave
knowing that 40,000 kilometers is the
length of the crater. Um, and that
can be a reference number. So you can,
when you see that you buy, um, you know,
Australia is one 10th of that African
north to south is one fifth of that.
It becomes something that's
in your head that you,
is it a ready reference for you to
come through to, to, to relate to.
And the seven and a half billion people
in the world and they're, you know,
these are numbers which if
you have them ready to hand,
they help you to make these yardstick
comparisons against things that you hear
about. And it may be budgets,
it may be populations.
It's stuff that when you hear something
on the new juice, you're saying,
hold on a minute.
That's not a big number because it
compares with that number in this way.
And that's, that's, that's
one of the techniques. Yeah.
Um,
you were saying that on your website
you have like a database of numbers you
compare it to. Yeah. Can you
tell us what some of them are?
I assume one is the 40,000.
Yeah. That's where I come from.
All sorts of things really.
I mean it's,
what I tried to do is to find numbers
that would make meaningful comparisons.
So some of them are just
sort of re routine households
or everyday objects like
the size of a post it note. Some of
them are things like, um, you know,
landmarks, the height of the empire
state building or the height of
the height of the Eiffel Tower with the
ACA. And one of the things that I, I,
that is on the website and in the book
is I try and find passive that is not,
is that comparing an interesting way?
So for example,
the empire state building is 5,000 posted
notes. Hi. You know, almost exactly.
I do the comparison to [inaudible]. Um,
and you get some really interesting,
interesting numbers that
come through and that has a,
it's an interesting function because
it makes you think about the numbers
themselves, but it's almost
like a triangle. You know,
he has the empire state building, he has
a posted note and he has a number 5,000,
and it gives you a little bit of a feel
for each of those points of the triangle.
When you think about them in that
relationship. Of course it, it,
it means nothing in terms of if,
you know,
there's no conspiracy theory here that
they designed it to fit the posted note.
Um,
but it's,
it's still studying at sticks in the mind
and that's an interesting way of going
about it. But yes, at the numbers, the
numbers on the website, off our things,
like at the length of the light Nile
river, you know, the population of Brazil,
there are numbers that you can
compare things to. Um, um, and,
and that, that's something that may or
may not be intriguing when you bring,
when you see them.
Thanks for the talk in the book.
So it seems that most of the things
you've talked about, at least so far,
I don't live in the book,
there's more,
but it's like about physical quantities
that you can kind of compare it,
like look at one versus the other.
What do you think,
do you think that the same strategies
apply to think things that are more in
material, like information and so
on. Like maybe a few years ago,
like thinking in megabytes would have
been fine. Now we're talking gigabytes.
So maybe it's a different, like
it's almost like unbounded,
uh, in a way, like the,
the kind of a amount of numbers, the size
of the numbers that these things are.
So you think,
so the first book is a book is it's more
physical things around us, you know,
it's white and it's Spanish,
isn't it? Things like that.
Second off of the book first gets
into certain numbers from science.
So we'd talk about how you can
visualize or start to grasp,
for example, the size of the observable
universe. You know, get there by stages,
you know,
um,
and there's a chapter on inflammation
and regarding going to things like, um,
how do you measure information,
that's all, you know,
how to information is contained in texts,
how information is stored in physical
devices and things like that.
Of course that part of the book is
out of date before it's published,
but nonetheless principles remain.
Um,
and then there's a chapter on
mathematical numbers as well. Um,
it's really not a book about mass,
but we have to touch on things like um,
you know,
explained that that infinity is not
actually a number on the number line or
you're talking about grams number,
which is an interesting,
he made a few grams number.
Yeah. I mean it's, it's, it's a,
it's a non both.
Um,
I first came across it when it was in
the Guinness Book of Records as the
largest number ever used in a
serious mathematical context I guess.
And Grimes number is just a recipe
for taking pallets of numbers and
unbelievably large number of times you
could not write down Graham's number,
the world, the universe would
not have space for it. Um,
so question is, you know,
is it even a number if it's all that
it is, is a, an algorithm for, for,
for doing computation red you
could never carry out. Um,
but actually even if I,
you know,
going buy a coffee and it cost me two
pounds 50, that number two pounds 50,
it's just an algorithm.
It's not the number itself.
There are some digits there and we are
heads of the algorithm for turning that
into a number. So there's no point of
principle difference between the two.
Thank you for the talk.
I have a question
because I mean my family,
like half of the kids don't
understand math. You know,
I was fortunate to understand it a bit,
but um,
do you think this like
understanding numbers should be,
have a bigger role in school because how
math is taught in Germany for instance?
Still Very, you know, basic. Yeah.
And very on the numbers rather
than on what the numbers mean.
I think there's an interesting
thing job cause I think,
I think math is a thing of beauty.
Math is math is a,
is an abstract thinking skill
of all subtlety and profanity.
Um,
and what we call
what I called numeracy.
Of course it touches on maths,
but it is not math.
It's dealing with numbers.
It's the way in which those abstractions
of maths connect to the real world.
Yeah. And I think, I mean I'm no
teacher, I'm an educational expert.
I can't speak with
authority on those matters.
But it seems to me that we leave behind
numbers due to live on two maths.
And I think that some of the things
I've been looking at Yarra suggest to me
that there's much more that we can do
in terms of what I would call adult
numeracy,
advanced numeracy to actually think about
numbers into the millions and billions
and trillions.
And
there's a shift that happens.
I mean we all,
when we start thinking and at junior
school we're thinking in terms of linear
numbers, linear scales. But truthfully,
the interesting stuff happens when you
start looking at more like logarithmic
scales. When you start thinking of things
in terms of, of multiples of each other.
Um, and when you, the way to understand
things like the size of the university,
you can't do it if you're thinking
in terms of a linear scar.
You've got to think in terms of what is
of magnitude in terms of powers and so
on. I think there's that sort
of numerous thinking. I don't,
I'm not aware that that's
part of the scope of our,
of school mathematics and I think it's
actually very important and it's very
useful to think in terms of, of, of,
of proportions rather than linear scales.
Thank you again.
Thank you all for your attention.